man I think it's Tito you take the guard
out or off Oh God
I just had a pretty invasive oral
surgery down here Hank this is
definitely the highest I've ever been
when making a vlog brothers video my
mouth hurts so bad Hank you know the
first time that I referenced this pain
that I still have was in my second vlog
brothers video in 2007 Hank as you know
I had surgery on my mouth a few weeks
ago after they sewed my gum back into my
mouth my mouth tasted like cement and
blood and burnt meat this is the fourth
and most dramatic surgery that I thought
there got to say I've got great care I
have a great oral surgeon great dentists
so I really am confident that this is
finally going to work but all chronic
pain is just the worst the thing about
physical pain Hank is that it's almost
inexpressible like there's this great
book the body in pain by Elaine Scarry
that talks about how like pain doesn't
just defy language it kind of destroys
language like it's just impossible to
use language to get other people to
understand what your physical pain is
like because your physical pain is
always only yours but anyway this
particular surgery was necessitated
because a metal rod had emerged from out
of my gum erupting from the skin and
pressing against my lip that's the best
that I can do to use language to
describe how much it hurt I think I'm
sorry this video isn't funnier oh is
that oh it's dried blood that's nice
that's a nice look for today but anyway
Hank in the last 24 hours I've been
thinking a lot about how lucky I am like
I have access to the best oral surgeons
and the best dentists so you know this
suffering is just necessary but there's
a lot of suffering that's completely
unnecessary and my favorite thing about
the nerdfighter community is that we try
to do stuff about that
so anyway thinking about that led me to
start a fundraiser over at Save the
Children to help them out with their
work with Syrian refugees Save the
Children is doing amazing work to get
kids in refugee camps access to health
care and education and nutrition so yeah
I started a fundraiser called
nerdfighters opposed to human suffering
including but not limited to John's
post-operative pain which a nerdfighter
on tumblr helpfully shortened to n/a HS
IB and l TJ P o P or as I like to call
it now see bunt with Tennant j-pop
nerdfighters I will match all your
donations up to $20,000 and I'm not just
saying that because
hi I asked Sara earlier if it was okay
and she said yes I think the only thing
I can really say about pain is that it
sucks I don't think it's romantic or
transcendent or any of that I think it
just sucks and I think where we can help
alleviate it we should so donate if you
can if not to this fundraiser than to
another and of course it's okay if you
can't donate as well you got to take
care of yourself
Alice needs me to read her in Elmo's
story so I got to go Hank I'll see you
on Friday